so questions hesitating if you're not
looking at it would you just posture
eyes on it now it's right there again
and it's a bit interesting because what
it's done and we've seen this before
is it taste or same kind of information
but because it sort of phrases in
Reverse what it just looks kind of weird
okay I'm just doing approach it in much
the same way which I'm gonna start with
the important details such as seventeen
and a half percent for holiday hey what
else do I know about this four weeks of
Norway juice and a 35-hour week four
weeks yeah and I think the last thing we
know is the total amount she earns over
those four weeks what is that number
twenty five thirty three point three
zero okay so this is weird because that
two thousand five hundred thirty three
dollars and thirty cents
it's usually where we end right it's
like here all the bits multiplied
together add and there's the final
number so now we have to go in reverse
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take these pieces inflation and
I'm literally gonna use them even relax
right now this is the total pain it
includes the holiday loaded right so
therefore like usually for instance I
might say I'm just making this number up
I might say oh okay I usually earn two
thousand dollars over the course of my
four weeks but I don't want to get my
learning so therefore I'm going to
multiply by the one hundred seventeen
and a half which includes the one
hundred and the symptom health agree so
this would give me the total amount
but I had the total amount and I want to
go in the other direction so instead of
multiplying by a hundred seven other
said I'm going to do mine
now once I do that I get a number out
because of the awkwardness of the
percentage that we're being asked for
you actually don't get a number of cents
you get six three three point three to
five I think
okay now I'm gonna pause it and look at
the question right CS is fine her
normally pay um my phone is that the
right number
no wait I've done something else I've
actually I've got a different number I'm
doing different
someone's I'm not gonna race to
something to one exactly yeah okay sorry
I was a line a hit now once you look at
that there are things I've taken the
looting out of the equation so this
amount here means that what that's what
she actually earned without the loading
animal okay so now I need to get to you
well if it's not per week that
represents four weeks right that's four
weeks so what I do in this now divided
by four so I'm gonna go to one five six
divided by the pool and I think that's
from memory anything about that night
I think it looks about right because
much fun for you
okay okay I'm gonna talk about the last
question that I've assigned in 1d good
boy once upon a time I could read one
day and it'll just be an innocent
combination of a number at all anyway
okay